it is through the personal
transformation of people that the world
is transformed it is not firstly through
political action through political
activism through all these things true
transformation happens through you
becoming a saint if you become a saint
then you will transform reality I'm not
against being politically active but if
you think that that's how you're going
to fundamentally change reality forget
it it's like let's take the United
States for example like you literally
have a country that's split 50/50 down
the middle and then everybody's fighting
for like the few percentages to win the
next election and so who is winning is
anybody going to win how you going to
win are you going to destroy 50% of the
country are you going to just eliminate
everybody like this kind of culture War
stuff is that's why I tried to avoid it
as much as I can because the problem of
the fragmentation is such a deep problem
it doesn't have a political
solution
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic
[Applause]
world but I did want to understand more
deeply what you were talking about about
the
Enlightenment and I guess um if the
world is going to be
re-enchanted then um what methodology
can we use to explain the world to
ourselves and each other because while
the enlightenment or that bundle of
thinkers and procedures that were born
at that time and kind of came together
while it does have problems and
certainly can't explain everything it
does have a way of like really drilling
down into so-called OB objective truth
like does like approach something more
solid and when we start speaking in
terms of
symbolism like what is the underlying
like methodology and how do you know
when you're going astray how do you
check your notes how do you like show
your work like like a math problem like
how do you like
verify
well how can I say this I think we're
looking at two different
problems right one is the problem of
let's say predicting phenomena which is
let's say uh quantifying and predicting
phenomena is very different from
understanding the very frame by which we
look at reality that is the frame of uh
hierarchies by which we organize the
world right those are those two things
are very different you could say it's
the difference between a hierarchy of
Virtues a hierarchy of values a
hierarchy of uh
importance and the the drilling down on
the identities that are identified once
that hierarchy is set up right so it's
like I decide what's most important and
then I apply the tools of reason or of
scientific methodology I can apply them
to certain phenomena that I identify and
then I can analyze them and so we can't
we can't measure both with the same the
same scope if we try then we fail it's
like it's like uh it's as if I'm trying
to tell you on the one hand to to uh put
on a scale you know the the the formula
for I don't know for certain you know
certain speeds or certain uh certain
phenomena and at the same time I'm
trying to help you understand why you
love your wife and then you say well how
do you how can you prove that you love
your wife like how and then and so we
this is the problem and so it doesn't
mean that love is a completely
subjective idiosyncratic thing it's just
that the the the the forms by which we
in which we approach the world are a
different type than the phenomena that
we analyze and that we quantify and so
they they they require different tools
different
intuitions and those intuitions do not
have to satisfy the re requirement of
someone who wants to know how to make
you know uh like gunpowder and what the
chemical formula is they're just not the
same
thing I don't know if that makes sense
no it does but the formula for gunpowder
works or doesn't work yeah how do we
know if the formula for hierarchy works
or doesn't work like like like there got
be some way to verify whether or not
you're right or wrong let me let's let's
let's use another example when it's
simpler let's
say how do you know like let's say
advertising
works right trying to convince people of
something uh using certain methods can
function okay but it doesn't function
100% of the time doesn't function with
every single person it's not the same
type of criteria and so you know that
there is a hierarchy of goods now the
idea that people won't completely agree
of how that hierarchy lays itself out
that is inevitable but to deny that
that's part of the mechanisms by which
we judge the world that is also a
problem because what happens when people
do that and you see that in the case
especially of the new atheist types is
that they do have a hierarchy by which
they ENT they entertain the world they
do have a hierarchy of Virtues and
values they take it for granted they
don't analyze it they don't identify it
they judge the world with it uh and then
they act as if it's just the it's just
the water in which they're swimming and
they can pretend that they're just being
scientists and and reasonable I'll give
you an example that's very simple that I
that I noticed once it was a discussion
between Sam Harris and uh and
Dawkins where they were talking about a
very controversial subject which is race
and
IQ and you know they were talking about
the studies that discussed this and then
Dawkin said I don't care about that
subject I don't think it's important to
talk about that and I thought like okay
Mr Dawkins by what criteria do you
decide that that's not high on your
hierarchy of values of things to study
and I would like for us to explore that
because as soon as you start to explore
that then you're in another sphere
you're not in the same sphere as the the
kind of rationalist scientist types
think that they always
inhabit and so the the difference of
care is is is part of that like what is
it that we care about and how that lays
itself
out MH and so the the answer is not a
simple one the answer is not like you
know if you follow this formula then
this is how it's going to it's going to
play out H it's it's more subtle because
it it has the problem of being the it
has the problem of looking at the
mechanism by which we how let's do it
this way yeah it has the problem of
Consciousness looking at itself right it
has the problem of intelligence looking
at itself and that is that is the you
could say it's the problem of human
knowledge and the problem of human
civilization it's the problem that's
encoded in every
single mythology every single you know
worldview that that that has laid itself
out since the beginning of time it's a
very it's a difficult problem it's the
problem that's happening in the Garden
of Eden right it's the problem these are
the problems that we're dealing with
they are very difficult because they
talk about the the question of how to
look at the frame by which I'm looking
at the world and so that's not easy so
it means that you know what what the
let's say the Saints would say and what
you know some of the philosophers would
say is that that or even like I don't
know a Zen Buddhist would say is that
you can arrive at those things by a type
of intuition Insight right you can
arrive at insight and that Insight is
not contained in the mechanisms that I'm
trying to to to bring about it's
contained in in the in the type of
grasping that happens right when you see
that things come together and all of a
sudden you see a kind of Shining Light
of of a of unity and you grasp it that's
inside yeah but inside cannot be uh can
very difficultly be explained by type of
discourse that rationalists want to use
okay I just spoke so you have so we have
a problem which is that which is that on
the one hand this is what all the
traditional things are talking about
right this is what so many of the
religious uh let's say the theologians
the mystics are talking about which is
the capacity for
insight but you can't totally describe
it you have to play around it you have
to skirt around it you have to point at
it and then when you have that ex so you
could say the same like you could let's
let's use an example that's very simple
it's not there's no woo woo here you
know it's it's like
I can tell you what it's like to to be
in love I can say it I can give you tell
you A Million Ways and what it what it's
like to be in love but unless you that
happens to you unless you grasp that
unless you reach that Insight you will
never you will never fully understand
what it is you have to you have to enter
into it with experience now the the
wayes we talk about it can help guide
you in that Insight can help stabilize
that Insight can help you but it's not
not enough you have to have you have to
kind of enter into that
experience and it's this actually this
is the same for everything that you
describe this is the same for anything
that has identity you know I can
describe a hammer all day long but the
grabbing the hammer in your hand and
using it that's that's the Insight of
the hammer and it's not it cannot be
reduced to its to its quantifiable
things can be reduced to its description
can be reduced even to its function
there's something about it which is more
and that is that is the very mysticism
that like that that that someone like
Lindsay wants to decry but you can't
avoid that because mysticism happens not
just in someone in some Saint's cave
where they're praying and they're having
a it happens every time you encounter
unity in the world every time you
transcend the multiplicity of of of uh
quantifiable things into to the unity
that binds them together you're having a
little mystical experience yeah that is
true for it's as true for a pencil as
it's true for falling in love or going
to church all these or or or you know
putting your hand on your on your breast
and and saying the Pledge of Allegiance
like these these things are all mystical
in their nature yeah but the issue then
is that when we observe um human
beings unifying in their
unification in a bigger group like once
they start to formulate or to congregate
through religions through uh Creeds
through political parties Nations
businesses uh about friendships um well
friendships is still like families and
friendships is still more organic but
once we get into a higher level like a
something Beyond a Township there's the
capacity for authoritarian ISM
totalitarianism
unification a unification the same in a
person a person can have an
authoritarian a person can try to apply
authoritarian principles to the multiple
aspects that constitute it right do that
all the time right they they deny
something about themselves right they
they just try to push it into the as if
it doesn't exist and they try to
compress right this idea of uh
repressing certain things in you that's
an authoritarian approach to a single
being yeah and so the authoritarian
approach can happen at every level of
unity from the person to the family to
the city to the state to the to the
basketball team to any type of unity can
is in danger of having that
characteristic there's no there's no way
around
it and so When approaching any given
group of people how does one Analyze
That to see if it's healthy or unhealthy
or good or bad or evil or or whatever
like like what what tool set how do you
describe that which allows you to assess
whether this
Unity is proper or
improper well the unity itself I mean
how can I say this unities are always
around a purpose right so you the first
of all the purpose can be bad right you
can have a street gang who's who the
fact of their Unity is to rob people and
kill people and so the purpose of the
unity that's what Unity is always d you
directed towards purpose and so you can
you can first of all identify the the
reason for the unity and that can be a
problem and then you can also look at
the mechanisms by which the unity is
manifesting itself which is that the you
know the uh the traditional Vision I
think of unity is something like a dance
between unity and multiplicity right
it's it's this kind of breathing in and
breathing out uh is it one of my
favorite quotes from roomy who talked
talks about you know he says yeah you
know if you if you keep your hand always
open or if you keep your hand always
closed you will be paralyzed but you
know actual experience is in the very
subtle moving o open and closed of the
hand that's how reality works is this
this subtle dance between unity and
multiplicity uh and that's how you can
recognize if something is balanced or
not and and it's so it's the same in a
family you can see that right it's like
if there's too much multiplicity then
it's chaos in the house and then you
know everybody's doing their own thing
and things are messy and nobody can and
everybody's screaming at each other uh
and if there's too much
Unity right then then everybody is
afraid and everybody is just in line and
just doing the things they need to do
and there's no variability there's no
joy there's no kind of uh and so you
have to always no matter what Unity you
participate in you always have to find a
balance between the two and that's true
of yourself by the way as well if you
work 24 hours a day you will collapse if
you play 24 hours a day you will
collapse and if you sleep 24 hours a day
you will collapse like there is a
balance of attention and distraction
there's a there's a balance of reason
and emotion all of these things are part
of how the human being functions uh and
If you deny one aspect of it then it
builds up and it explodes and by the way
this is my critique of of the kind of
rationalist Enlightenment mode is that
it
ignores aspect of reality it just
says just says don't do that don't be
unreasonable you know don't follow your
emotions just be just be reasonable and
logical and and uh and scientific and
you'll be fine right and that's the
equivalent of saying you know you could
work 20 24 hours a day if you just don't
sleep Benjamin you know just don't sleep
and if you sleep I'll tell you oh I told
you not to sleep why are you sleeping if
you become distracted I'll say well why
are you being distracted Benjamin I told
you just pay attention I it seems like
you're not following what I'm saying if
you just did what I said then the world
would be perfect and everything would
flow like like you know would flow
wonderfully and so this is the problem
with the this is the problem with the
Stephen Pinker and kind of you know
Hicks and all of these these kind of
Enlightenment types is that they they
decry an aspect of humanity which is
part of humanity and is not only part
but is inevitable to humanity and then
they're surprised when they watch it
blow up they're surprised when they see
it explode in front of them and they're
like well no we said just be reasonable
and uh you know just follow these these
things and if you do then you'll be fine
and this is where we are now by the way
this is the moment where we've reached
which is
that the things that the enlightenment
ignored which is for example the means
by which we attain
Unity that's now exploding in
everybody's face
they said just be reasonable be rational
if we're just rational and scientific
and we we develop scientific things and
more machines and more and more uh you
know and more technology and more
science then we'll all be we'll be we'll
have food and and wealth and money and
then we'll be happy right but sadly
that's not what's
happening that's obviously not what's
happening and now that narrative is
exploding and it's exploding in the very
mechanisms but that gave birth to it
which is that now we have we have people
at open AI doing rituals and invoking
who knows what you know into their into
their AI God and everybody's surprised
as if this is as if this was not
something that has been building up
since after World War II
basically well I mean I guess we are in
the shadow of World War Two where let's
just say um various different powers and
principalities organized in various
different ways uh we have uh Japan we
have Germany Germany became uh or Italy
became fascist Germany became National
Socialist and they began to purge their
population to create some sort of very
incredibly sharp like un intention like
one very sharp unity and since then you
know America and the Allies come and
like they break apart the unity or the
unity breaks itself apart or it causes a
reaction in other parts of the
multiplicity of humanity to to kind of
counter
um but in the north Americas at least
we're we're very wary of unity again we
we see um I guess this guy Rob Riner
who's like this bleeding heart liberal
on Twitter uh always decrying the far
right he never talks about the right he
always talks about the extreme right the
far only the far right there there's
only the extreme right and uh you know
he's he I think he's producing a
documentary about Christian
nationalism um but his entire mode is
Christian nationalist it's just progress
it's just a version of Christianity that
purged religious talk out of it but just
transferred all these religious Concepts
onto the Notions of humanity and
progress um but it's it's the same like
that's the real Christian nationalism is
woke it's the one that's infected every
part of our uh governing apparatus
that's Christian nationalism is just
Downstream from an older version of
itself but I so I have like I have
sympathy for for by the way for James's
position which he says like is preparing
a big scop I totally agree with him I
agree with him that of what he's scared
of which is that the the farle or the
the the kind of activist left will use
the the Resurgence of the relationship
between Christianity and nationalism to
attack the nation itself and to attack
the idea of the nation and of the and of
the you know your Constitution or
whatever by the way I'm not American I
always have to remind people of that
your Constitution and all these things
like I I completely agree with him but I
think that I think that the mechanisms
by which he is approaching that are
going to be counterproductive for his
whatever his cause is you know
because how can I say this it's
like let's ask this question uh for
America why is America a
nation because we are a nation at this
point that's right go just take it for
granted there we're just a we're just a
bunch of people in a land you know and
uh that's it that's it and so that so
this is the problem that we're that
we're coming towards is that if we've
haven't asked ourselves wouldn't make
something one for a few hundred years
actually we have you're right so there
it's there's Extremes in the
enlightenment world right the
enlightenment world the the world after
the enlightenment I tried to describe it
in as two extremes that are are getting
further from each other so if you want
to say Enlightenment and counter
Enlightenment whatever that's fine just
as long as you understand that they're
both caused by the same thing that
they're both causing each other right if
you want to use the word counter
Enlightenment I I don't like it because
it makes it feel too simplistic but you
have in so on the one hand you have an
increase in let's say uh you could you
could call it like lower identities
right and then you also have the
opposite which is is the desire to kind
of break them down and so you have
nationalisms that become strong right
the the nation state is a is a
post-enlightenment phenomena it's not an
ancient phenomena the way that we
understand Nations and borders and
governments and states and and
bureaucracies these are not the the
ancient ways of thinking these are post
Enlightenment uh structures and so you
have the nation which grows and then you
have something like the anti- nation or
or globalism or communism or
revolutionary like there there's a
tendency to want to dis to deconstruct
that which is being set up as being
stronger and stronger and so this is
still playing out now like that the the
same things that led to World War II you
know are still playing out today because
we haven't dealt with any of it we
haven't looked at the root cause of of
the problems we've brought about both
the nationalism and the communism in in
the early 20th century and so now we
have the same problem happening in
different guises and once again Lindsay
is absolutely right to see the insane
postmodernism as a continuation of the
Revolutionary and communist uh things
that burgeoned up in the in the 19th and
early 20th
century but these things are G are H are
are going to happen and and let's say
the nationalism the C the centralism is
going to keep peing too at the same time
and so the globalist tendency towards C
centralism and the weird things we saw
happened during covid They're all
playing out the same patterns of a
separation of unity and multiplicity so
it's like people emphasizing too much
unity and then people emphasizing too
much multiplicity Happ happening
simultaneously so we see kind of global
structures of power manifesting
themselves and deconstructing uh Powers
happening at the same time you know I
you know we wrote uh Jordan Peterson and
I wrote a an essay for Ark recently on
this problem you know which is trying to
articulate subsidiarity as the right
relationship between unity and
multiplicity all across different levels
right the idea what do you mean by
subsidiarity subsidiarity it is the
idea that there is this tendency to move
towards Unity let's say to a unified
State the the ultimate image of this is
something like the state and the people
right so we have people that are just
they just spread out on a on a board
right they they have no connection
between each other they're just all
atomized individuals and then on top of
that you have a state which is becoming
more and more powerful and more and more
controlling and those two Tendencies
play on each other that is the the
anarchic tendency of the modern world
the tendency to deconstruct into atomize
individuals feeds the tyan tyrannical
system because as we atomize because as
we atomize and as we're not no longer
connected in little groups like families
like like clubs you know like parishes
all of these things those those uh
functions have to be covered by
something and so charity can't if I'm
not like taking care of my parents when
they're old then the state has to
provide for that right the state has to
create old people's homes with like you
know with with with Taxation and funding
or whatever and so as you as you
disconnect from down here you're you're
demanding even even if you're even if
you're revolutionary in your attitude if
you're saying if you even if you're a
hippie and you're like yeah screw the
system break this down you know you know
you have to liberate yourself from
family from religion from all these
things and all be a bunch of anarchist
uh you know living living all apart from
each other that's calling the system to
to become more and more powerful so
those are the two like Tendencies you
could say of the words world since the
Enlightenment and you can see it right
from the outset with lock and Hobs you
know Hobs is an authoritarian for reason
because he understands that reason is
centralized thing that comes down and
he's like we're going to impose this
reason and these principles on the
people that are that are going and that
end up becoming more and more atomized
as time goes forward so what we're
trying to articulate is
that the the the principle of
subsidiarity which is the idea that you
are you are made of Multiplicity
yourself right you already have multiple
subpersonalities inside you and that and
then you have to unite them in a person
and that person has to be United in a
family and those families have to be
united into neighborhoods into into
cities into all all kinds of parallel
structures like clubs like you know like
I don't know the Boy Scouts or and the
church and the sports teams and all of
these things and this is actually how
how reality scaffolds itself how it kind
of builds both unity and resilience at
the same
time now the the the problem we've got
now is you've got these two things like
there's no by the way there's very
little difference between the
libertarian anarcho libertarian types
and the Rainbow Coalition types they're
basically saying the same thing they're
saying I can self-define myself
completely I can just be me and I can
completely be independent and and I
don't need anything you know above me
which is which is kind of uh exercising
authority over me and that's and that
when you do that it calls for it calls
for tyranny and that's what that's why
why that's what happened in so many of
the revolutions is that Revolution is
followed by tyranny because Anarchy
calls for authority
authority the problem that James brings
up is
that like there's on a certain level
like um the right the dissonant right
the counter Enlightenment that they they
want to impose some sort of structure
right a religious person wants to impose
their religious structure on the world
and is saying you can't tell me what to
do you're not God no one person is God
so how does
humankind because if you look at
liberalism it's nice that you get to be
an orthodox person I get to do my uh my
spiritual practice you know and my
parents can be Christian you know and
and we can coexist and kind of have a
different framework or a different
practice but still somehow come together
and the the the liberal project of
allowing these uh this multiplicity of
religious belief a multiplicity of like
higher level uh Transcendent orders um
is kind of nice it's nice to have
Muslims getting along with Christians
getting along with Jews and then not
demanding
one you know one structure or who
demands that and and if if what you're
saying is that it's unstable on some
level to allow for multiplicity on some
level or we Unity is going to happen
Unity is inevitable like how does one
navigate in a post uh post-religious or
post- unified religious world all these
different you know how it happens and
you know how we navigate we end up with
the with the the the WF and the and the
and the wh and the UN and that's what we
end up with right it's it's funny that
it's like oh I don't want any type of
moral order over me as as you're saying
that and as the entire world since the
1960s hippies have been saying that you
could you watch these structures become
more and more powerful and become more
and more encompassing and Technology
making it possible and
so it's like can I say this it's this is
not like I'm not an
idealist I I I hope you understand this
like I'm not I'm not saying we're going
to reach some perfect Utopia and that
we're going to find the solution to
everything okay uh but what I can see is
that there is in this process of moving
towards multiplicity and towards more
and more
Unity right now the nation state is in
danger because there is no justification
for the nation
state there's no like basic
philosophical justification for its
existence on its own unless we have what
I believe to be this kind of subsidiary
subsidiary notion that we kind of
participate in identities all the way
through and so
I agree that the problem of you know a
kind of let's say Islamic approach to
Christianity you know a kind of uh idea
that right now we could impose you know
I don't know like some kind of Christian
hierarchy over the West I think that's a
ridiculous idea and I've never advocated
for that once in my entire why is that
ridiculous well
because I don't know do you think that's
possible
I don't think it's possible but so it's
a ridiculous idea deposit an idea that's
not possible is wasting your time and
wasting your energy and is not like what
are you try what do you think is gonna
happen like for anybody that I don't I
don't think I've ever met anybody who
thinks that by the way but if there are
people who think that the only way to do
that would be through massive
violence like on the OWN on your own
people is that what you would do to
impose well no you're right I think it
is happening it's just called
progressivism and it's what like that is
Christian nationalism that is just
Christianity without uh without the
cross in some way without sacrifice it's
really it's interesting phenomen it's
EXA it's taken a lot of like the
morality of Christianity and then like
try to liberate it from like this kind
of crusty way of thinking that's
traditional and symbolic and it's tried
to impose it on bureaucratic levels you
know with like these flags and these
rambos you can see it producing
symbolism that keeps on getting really
icky and yucky you know but it's cuz it
there's no order in it but it is trying
to order the world and it is trying to
take over you you have to in order to be
uh you know increasingly in order to get
ahead in Academia you have to believe in
this way of thinking this Dei stuff and
diversity equity and inclusion they're
all kind of uh adapted Christian values
of of unity it's a religious thing for
sure yeah it's definitely religious but
this is what this is again like if to
come back to the the the statement that
started this whole argument for example
with me and James is that this is
happening right it's like the world is
is becoming religious again I don't
think it ever totally stopped being
religious but it's happening at a very
fast speed and the image of that
religiosity right now is exactly that
it's like trans is sacred that's the
image of the religiosity it's like it's
like I am you know you saw that speech
in the in the Joon of Arc uh play that
got put online for like a week and then
scrubbed from the internet as if it
never existed where it was basically
saying you know I transcend mo i
transcend uh uh categories you know I am
Transcendent because I am not one thing
I'm like the Trinity I am you know
transcended in every way and it's like
that's what we're heading towards you
know uh
and
so the
the the problem is that we do need
unity in order to function and what's
happening now is is we're being provided
with a a sacred
Narrative of unity which is actually a
kind of uh Paradox of Multiplicity right
it's saying something like multiplicity
is our Unity right it's multiplicity is
the only that that that you know
diversity is our strength as said our
friend Justin Trudeau uh but that's what
that aesthetic is it's basically it's
like reducing us all to the most
idiosyncratic thing that we can find and
making that into a kind of transcendent
good that is to be worshiped uh but that
that uh that that leads to more that
just leads to tyranny it just leads to
more tyranny that's why the Glo that's
why like people are confused by the way
like like what's the relationship
between globalism and like LGBT activism
you think like how rid because LGBT
activism is like is excessive and it has
a kind of Aesthetics of of of Carnival
and Jubilation and and uh you know in
excess and all that and how does that
fit with like environmentalism and covid
mandates and all of this kind of
tyrannical thing and the answer is it
does perfectly if you understand how
these two opposites basically feed each
other
how one gives birth to the other how the
the the controlling State wants as much
idiosyncrasy as possible and the the the
development of idiosyncrasy calls for
centralization but what's the moderate
answer to that like what's the what's
the alternative to that I think the
alternative is really a subsidiary
vision of reality it really is this idea
that we are all made of multip mcity
multiplicity is part of unity right it's
that which constitute Unity everything
has a center and a margin everything has
an identity and things that don't
totally fit and so we we both aim
towards the center and have compassion
for the margin right this is the
Christian message is to say like
basically say I I I see the ideal and I
aim towards the ideal but I reach out in
love to those that that don't fit that
ideal I you know I give that I give them
a hand and in compassion and love
without compromising the ideal and so I
say I say things
like I say I say very hard things like
you know the the purpose of sexuality is
to have children and sexuality should be
lived in a monogamous you know marriage
without
divorce that's the ideal and then I look
at myself then I look at everybody
around me and I realize nobody reaches
that ideal nobody nobody lives that
perfect L everybody failed everybody's
broken everybody is a part of that ideal
but I don't compromise the ideal for the
fact that we don't fit we I rather use
love and
compassion uh you know to the people
around me so to me that's the only way
to go is that's the only solution for
the problem of identity is that we it's
like it's neither tyrannical identity
that eliminates all all the uh all the
margin which is what you saw in the
Nazis for example and and in kind of
extreme nationalism right nor is it just
pure idiosyncrasy and anything goes and
and everything is equal and and all
values are equivalent like those two
things are not are not possible and and
and I don't say that as I'm not even
talking about a political system like
everything I talk I never talk about
political systems well that's that's the
danger though because it's going to
translate into politics somehow like Ark
if ark's going to do anything it's going
to have a political impact so it's going
to propose some sort of unity it's going
to propose some sort of alternative like
you say there's all these different
identities it's going to have to claim
that there's a global a proper Global
identity it's going to have to claim
that there's a proper use for something
like the UN the WF some sort of Masters
of the Universe experts you know who who
are in control of power arc Arc one of
the fing founding principles of Arc is
no compulsion like that has been from
the very beginning from Jordan Peterson
and you know there are certain reasons
why I participated in Arc you know I
have my doubts about Arc as much as
anybody because I don't want it also to
become a kind of right-wing WF which is
possible like that could happen until up
to now I don't see that happening it
cannot happen if something if
something's going to propose to start to
Define things on that level it's going
to have to emulate that definition so
when you get the definition we propose
is sub
it what if that's a definition we propos
yeah okay so fine you're saying that
you're proposing that there's levels to
the universe you're still going to have
to do the eye of the pyramid what is at
the top of that pyramid and then what's
next to the top to be God okay and then
what's right under God like the pope or
the the fathers the church fathers right
well I would say the the I mean of
course as a Christian I would say the
Saints you know uh and the testimony of
the of the Saints not not the human
authorities that are alive today and
have power well yeah but eventually
you're going to get to the people so
you're you're you're proposing all these
things that are but like there's
eventually there's a line eventually
there's the Masters of the Universe like
the highest human people who are alive
like and what does that system look like
so the system a subsidiary the way a
subsidiary system looks like is one
which many people can understand which
is
that higher levels of authority do not
mean that they have power over direct
power over lower parts of the per
pyramid you could say and so for example
you we have that in our everyday World
which is the president of the United
States cannot tell the mayor of Chicago
what to do okay right because the mayor
of Chicago has its own has his own
principality yeah and what do you mean
what why are because uh yeah directly no
indirectly absolutely Federal funding
like the system itself incentivizes or
disincentivizes certain sorts of uh
behaviors through funding that's why we
have issues with the civil rights law
right now because it's being used to
enforce uh extra like like it's it's
being used to sculpt culture and to tell
people what to do that is not in the
actual documents of the Constitution
right like the government's not supposed
to tell you how to associate what to
think but through civil rights law it
now has the power to influence that and
then it has the power to uh tell schools
what to do that's why we have you know
like with with the Obama Administration
you just have you watch this thing with
the gender issue it's self like going
into schools and and and pushing a
certain ideology through the schools so
no uh Biden can't tell uh Nome what to
do but the whole system itself tells
itself what to
do okay so there is a there is a
unbalanced move towards centralism let's
say that has happened over time in in
the modern State that's the modern State
itself seems to lend itself to that to
that problem which is like to kind of
move towards towards centralism uh but
it doesn't take away the basic idea
let's say so the problem is
that what I'm calling for people to do
is to participate in that kind of
subsidiarity from the bottom up right is
to understand that you are a person that
you are part of a family and that family
can participate in communities that you
can be engaged in your local uh
surroundings in your church in your
sports teams or whatever and to see that
as being being absolutely real and the
and the foundation on which your
experience of reality functions and the
scaffolding on which reality is built
and I I don't see any other way except
from a bottom up way
of I don't I don't there's no other way
because like you said the only the only
way that you would do it differently
would be to create an alternative
tyranny to the to the to the Tyranny
that's there at this moment which is why
just like just like Jordan Peterson I
agree with him when he said clean your
room like not in obviously it seems PR
when you say that but it's like the only
thing you can really do is be the best
friend the best father the best you know
the best
connected uh part of this scaffolding of
reality and that will have ripples right
it will transform things because the
system that we're in this kind of move
towards over centralization and more and
more centralization and the move towards
more and more insane levels of
idiosyncrasy and kind of self-naming and
and self-creating it cannot sustained
for a long time there's just no way it
can't hold and so you know like I'm not
a I don't want to be Doom and Gloom but
I think that out of the ashes of
whatever is coming will be those that
had that had a strong Network around
them that have friends and family and
that have and that are part that are
connected locally that's what going to
rise out of this
because because I I agree and that's why
if if Arc ever tries to be
something
um akin to the WF or the UN or some kind
of legislating body or some some type of
institution that tries to directly
influence uh laws in different countries
then you can you'll watch me run out of
that with that 100 miles an hour but
with the people that are there now I
don't think that's going to end danger
of happening anytime soon obviously any
any structure can be captured that's
obvious we've saw that we've seen that
happen you know you saw that happen uh
Over Our Generations but um I don't yeah
at least for now I don't see that as
part of the people that I've met
there so we've been talking like this
really abstract sociological level I I
kind of want to like invert the question
because in my conversation with James
eventually we have to get to Define what
an individual is like if if you know
that's like the building block uh for at
least he brought that up like that
nobody's really defined individual like
what is the individual and I was asking
him and he's like uh so he's working on
that it's like so what is an individual
because that's a very important piece of
the puzzle um because if you want to
preserve individual rights then you have
to Define an individual against a
collective or in a collective uh and
you're saying that there's all this
subsidary multiplicity identity indiv
uality multiple Unity individuality
Unity over and over and over this is the
problem of even phrasing it as
individual and Collective like to me
that's already a problem like it to to
just understand someone as an individual
facing a collective is the beginning of
what we're seeing now it's the beginning
of the individual becoming more atomized
and the collective being more and more
let's say encompassing so that you end
up with these weird systems that we're
in now that is not so I would say that
even like for example like in Christian
theology we we use the word person it's
a much better I think a better word than
the word individual which is that the
person is already in relationship with
others right the idea that you are that
you can
completely completely isolate an
individual from everybody else is very
difficult now I understand why you have
to do that to some extent in the law
that is that that seems necessary um to
avoid certain problems but I don't I
think it's dangerous to do it
fundamentally philosophically to kind of
isolate the individual but you could see
that you could just say that a person is
a locust of Consciousness like that I
don't I don't think that that's is that
that weird of a of a way to to to to
understand that well I mean you're
you're you're answering the qu let me
just ask the question so it can be on
record what is a person what is a man
what is a human
a yeah a human and so I would say that I
think that's what the that's what I
would say I would say you know a person
is a locust of Consciousness and that is
you know in the image of God in the
sense that it is not completely isolated
lcus of Consciousness right it's a it's
a lcus of Consciousness that
reflects a higher Consciousness or
higher consciousnesses however you want
to say that uh and then that that
engages with other persons that engages
with other faces other people facing
them and and form bonds and communities
and also to some extent
exist with and in each other like we
don't we don't exist completely uh alone
from each other we we we exist with and
and in each other and to me that's the
and so the the ultimate image of a
person isn't is a person in the
communion of love it's not a person on
their own you know I don't know standing
on the corner with a with a sign asking
for their rights not that we shouldn't
have rights of people but that the
ultimate image of a person is a person
in a communion of love that's that's
what a person is okay what is this love
thing that you're talking about this
love thing yeah it's the thing that
binds you it's that love is that which
binds binds how how would you how would
you teach a 10-year-old old boy to
to to move towards proper love and move
away from improper love cuz there's
improper ways of binding of course yeah
and so that like the entire you could
say that the entire uh history of of
Christian theology is about
understanding proper love you could
say and you know actually you know it's
interesting Dante is probably one of the
best ones if you want to look at how to
deal with proper love Dante has a great
ntis comedy is one of the best
examinations of that um which is that
care right we could use the word care
the word care is is is is is better
because it today with haiger people kind
of understand it a little more right
it's like care is that which makes you
move right you don't do anything without
care right if I go from here to the door
is because I have a reason to if I right
if I eat an apple it's because I have
have a reason to it's like there's care
that is motivating me towards you could
say the rest from that care right if I'm
hungry I eat and I hope to find rest
from my desire in that in that in that
movement and that is what motivates all
our action right so you could say that
the world is built in care built by care
um and so there are hierarchies of care
there are things that make us live more
than others
and if we if we get that wrong then
obviously we we're in trouble right and
so you could say something like food is
good and we should care for it but
there's a limit to which we should care
for food it should be anchored in
something that we care for more okay
because if we just if we care for food
as the ultimate thing that we love then
you know we'll become unhealthy and fat
and whatever and that's true of all the
things that we care about you know you
can become you can become possessed by
anything if you care for it too much you
know whether it's money whether it's sex
whether it's I don't know it's like
success or Prestige or whatever it is
like and all of those things are good
all of them but they're just good at the
level that they should and that's why we
we you know in the the idea of
Christian the Christian theology rep you
know structures the world that way and
so the love of others you know is more
important first of all than let's say
the love of things like that's the
that's a beginning it's like if I care
for others then I get more life than if
I care for my car like if I if I love my
my wife and my kids then I get more and
I have more uh there's more reality in
my life than if I if I love my car and
my car is fine I can love my car to some
extent it just has to right has properly
organized and that but that SC SC also
and you can understand that the love of
Virtues for example and if I if I
understand that certain virtues also
provide life to me
truth beauty
um you know and that if I love goodness
right that's the I'm almost like a
neoplatonist now like if I love the good
itself then I am aiming towards the
highest the highest and I'm kind of
moving
up the the the this hierarchy of love
you could say um so does that make sense
in in in terms of understanding what
love
is um it was a trick question but uh
asking me what love is a trick question
I mean what did I not see in your
trick I mean can you really answer that
question can one
really answer what love is I don't know
that's the it's a tricky question let me
put it that way but um when when you get
to something like uh making meaning of
things on a collective level like
through religion on the level of
religion or on the level of absence of
religion or the the uh I guess the uh
it's not really an absence I guess
that's your point that's my point it's
like well it's still there it's just
like it looks like it's not there you
know it's just the the there is no
absence of religion that's an that's if
there's any illusion that's the illusion
why is that an
illusion because we we need things to
bind us together and those things that
bind us together they are purposes and
their orders right there's a purpose and
an order to a Binding Together right
there's a reason why there's a purpose
for this pencil and there's an order to
it there's a pattern by which I
recognize it's being so there's a
there's a purpose and in order that's
true for everything that we care about
as humans yeah and then it's especially
true of the things we care about as
humans amongst each other yeah which is
that a family
meal is has purpose and order a family
meal is a ritual is a ritual offered to
the unity of our family and it has to
have a certain form it's not it there's
variability in the form it's not like
every family meal is exactly the same
but there's a limit to that variability
right because if I come to the family
meal drunk then I'm going to break the
family meal right if I stand on the
table or if I lay on the floor during
the family meal then I'm going to break
the order of that meal which is aimed
towards its purpose that that uh that's
a little religious
ceremony family meal is a little
religious ceremony and then a game a
sports game is a little religious
ceremony we come together together with
a purpose there's an order there's a
celebration there's all these things
that we're doing together we we we wear
uniforms and we wear funny hats all the
things that people make fun of for
religion is there in a basketball game
or in a in a baseball game and so it is
the means by which we bind together
now what people now call explicitly
religious is when we gum together and we
unify under a Transcendent good which we
unify under into something which is uh
beyond our particularities in every in
every way right that's what that is but
if
you so if you take a take a a village
like in Quebec it's it's quite nice like
because we we in Quebec used to be very
Catholic I'm not Catholic by the way so
every village had a church right and the
church is the place where we would go
and we would celebrate
births uh weddings baptisms funerals all
the things that help us recognize that
we care for each other were celebrated
at the church in light of something
which transcends all of us and which
binds us all together all of humanity is
bound together under this this canopy
that we're now celebrating the things
that bind us together in that space
now if you take the church out you're
like well we don't need this thing just
get rid of it and all now we just need
we just we just we'll just be together
with reason we'll be reasonable and
we'll we'll have reasonable reason
together uh and and then you're
surprised that that like two generations
later people aren't getting
married right people have no initiations
at all for their children you don't know
your neighbor you don't care for your
neighbor you live in a suburb now and
there's no downtown and there's no place
to even walk at as a as a together as a
community you have malls you have houses
and you just are scattered on a board
like uh you know like a bunch of dots
and then you're like well how did this
happen what happened and it's like
that's exactly what happened is that you
try you thought that you didn't need
something to bind you together at a
higher level and then that Unity breaks
down yeah at every level after that it's
but pointing out the problem invites the
answer the solution so like how do you
go from Suburbia back to Village Life
you can't like how do you put the church
back in I mean you have these mega
churches America comes up with these
different ways of doing that like with
you know like Prosperity gospels
different things that serve that
function sporting events stuff like that
uh the woke stuff like is the is kind of
playing with the same
thing and your role is somebody who
whether or not you you you want to admit
you're prizz a certain religious
framework um and then you're you're uh
you're not imposing but superimposing it
by by taking bits of culture and
explaining it like you explain like
these little phenomena like okay well
here and you're you're describing a
pattern and you're very good at
describing the pattern without imposing
like your framework on it but you do
have a framework that you live within
you're icon Carver you believe in the
Transcendent Christ God Saints all that
stuff
it sounds like you it could be the case
I don't mean this as an accusation but
it's like you're kind of playing both
sides you're like well I don't I don't
want to impose my order but somebody's
got to impose the order some the the
order is going to be imposed and my
order is better than other orders but
maybe you don't want to say that so you
you you talk about in terms of Virtues
you talk you I talk about it in terms of
I talk about it in terms of groundup
participation that's how I talk up okay
not like go to church I say I say go to
go to church be deliberate about the
communities that you have be deliberate
about your family be deliberate about
the people around you be deliberate
about uh you know the the ways in which
you can participate and that will in the
end be the only Bull workk against
what's coming and so I really don't see
uh I really don't see so your humility
or like your
uh you're stopping from imposing your
order on other people it is not uh
because uh it's not false humility uh
it's not it's not like a trick it's
you're saying you have to find that for
yourself but you're going to have to
find it so find it deliberately this is
what I've found but you have to go forth
and find
it so you're not really
prizing it apparently orthod believe no
but I do believe that Christianity I do
believe Christianity is the is the best
story the way the truth in the life
don't hide that at all but I I also
don't see how that if that's the best
story I really don't see how imposing it
on people is going to be useful uh you
know if it's I'm trying to show the
beauty of that story and the the power
of that story so that people you know
want to participate but I don't see the
I mean I the idea of imposing it top
Town yeah you know in this world is is a
ridiculous to me is just a would be a
ridiculous proposition yeah and are
there really people who think that like
honestly you met anybody who who says we
should have uh we should impose
Christianity top down in the United
States like as does have you ever met
one person who says that uh you can
construe certain people's
um fantasy like that's what I think it
is I don't think that there are I don't
think that there are people who who who
say that
I there is a worry maybe it's a maybe
it's a St I'm trying to steal me on the
strum I'm trying to say to what extent
can you avoid
tyranny to what extent and and I'm just
trying to flesh out your attitude of and
and you said it you you indicated it or
hinted at it and that you said this is
the best story why would I impose the
best story it's just the best story I'll
just tell the story and it'll prove
itself it's the same thing with 2 + 2al
4 which is something I kind of like
flippantly brought up with James when we
were talking about symbolism like 2 plus
2al 4 is some sort of symbolic order um
and and he's and I'm like don't isn't
that like isn't that like authoritarian
like don't you impose that on the world
he's like no it's truth you just say it
is truth if you if you stray from the
truth you won't get anywhere so it's
just like 2 plus 2 equals 4 is the best
story Christianity isn't necessarily 2
plus 2 equals 4 that's the weird thing
about it and that's when you talk you
kind of have to I I have to immerse
myself in in your way of thinking cuz
you're not really telling me this this
methodology but you're always kind of
using this methodology you're picking up
symbols you're you're telling the story
you kind of have a map about hierarchy
and subsidiarity and unity and
multiplicity you have key words that
you're doing it and then when we drill
down into your story you can talk about
like the actual um we could probably go
into like any given verse of the Bible
any given passage of the Bible and you
could start to play with that and I
could see in your relationship to that
sacred text of yours the truth of it but
it's not like it's not going to be coded
in in the same way that 2 plus 2 equals
4 is going to be so I'm just trying to
say if people are worried about
Christian nationalism if people are
worried that you are fomenting some sort
of
tyranny like I'm I'm
try any of my content how could anybody
watch any of my content think that I'm
fomenting a kind of tyranny I don't
think that's possible well because
people are scared that in the post if
you're not for liberalism if you're
saying that that liberalism is
insufficient that therefore you're
trying to impose some sort of unity like
but it sounds like you're saying Unity
is going to happen and there's better
and worse forms of unity so I would
rather each individual work on their own
unities from the bottom up work on
themselves work on their family and then
that's the only way we can have order
that's sustainable and that's good for
all is that if it comes from ordered
people
it comes more I I totally think that
that's true you know the the pillar you
could say you know the pillars of the
church are the Saints that's how we
understand it in in the Orthodox
tradition which is that that's a
symbolic way of what do you mean the
pillars of the church are the same like
that's the this your total poetry like
what does that mean the pillars of the
chur I mean is that it is through the it
is through the personal transformation
of
people that the world is transformed it
is not it is not first in for and and
and firstly through political action
through political activism through all
these things that true transformation
happens through you becoming a saint if
you become a saint then then you will
transform reality if you if you create
I'm not against being politically active
but if you think that that's how you're
going to fundamentally change reality
then forget it it's like let's take the
United States for example
like it the culture war is the most
ridiculous thing in the universe and
when you look at it just just from just
one step you know away from each other
it's like you you literally have a
country that split 5050 down the middle
and then everybody's fighting for like
the few percentages to win the next
election and so who is winning would you
think is anybody going to win how are
you going to win are you going to
destroy 50% of the country are you going
to just eliminate everybody like there's
no this idea that this kind of culture
War stuff is that's why I tried to avoid
it as much as I can I obviously I get
dragged in once in a while but I Tred to
avoid that kind of stuff as much as I
can because you know how are you going
to the problem the problem of the
fragmentation is such a deep problem
that it doesn't have a political
solution you know that the anyways
that's that is that is how I that's why
I don't advocate for political Solutions
because you're not going to conquer 50%
of your
country with a with what with an
election like what what difference does
it make it and and people like even now
like even when I see you know I'm a
Christian for example I'm a Christian I
am against uh like I'm against abortion
it's a moral thing I'm against all the
things that Christians are against but
but people rejoicing because they
overturn some law in the United States
and thinking that now they're the tide
has changed like they're winning the
culture War it's just the most
ridiculous ridiculous thing ever this is
ridiculous like you have half the
population against you and you think
that you've overturned the law and now
like this is it like we're gonna we're
we've got it we're moving towards
Victory the the problem is so deep that
I do believe that the only thing that
can solve it is Saints in the sense of
transformed
people transformed families transformed
communities that will be like beacons
for a world that is that is is lost in
despair so if you can be someone that
other people want to imitate that is a
much better thing to be than winning
getting some law passed and and thinking
that now you you finally got like the
right amount of people on the Supreme
Court so now now we can do the thing
it's like the these these Solutions are
are are heading towards Civil War is
what they're heading towards yeah and I
and I I don't know I'm not saying like
you should just do nothing and sit
around and wait for the other side to
take you over if you're on one side of
that cultural divide but that you're not
going to find a solution there it's not
going to there's no long-term solution
in this kind of political fight well
where does where does sainthood start
where does this transformed person start
to transform where have you seen it like
in in your own life or in the lives of
others where you start to see that
change happening yeah you have to start
you have to look at your sins right
instead of just looking at the sins of
others you have to see your own sins
right see the places where you fall
short of the ideal see the places where
you lie the places where you where you
where you twist reality to fit your
narrative where instead of just looking
at how the others do it right try start
by doing it on your own on yourself I
mean don't be naive right don't be an
idiot and just and and ignore when let's
say things are being Twisted by your
enemy but you have to start with
yourself and and that is I think the
solution ultimately and so whether it's
politically whether it's personally you
know whether it's in your personal
relationships whether it is in your own
bad habits whether it is all these
things that's the
beginning right to not be a hypocrite to
not you know and we're all Hypocrites we
we we all have to work on that but I
think that that's the that's the place
to start right it really
is I mean that's what you know it's like
that's what that's what Jesus said
that's what the Saints always say the
Saints always say that say transform
yourself you know forgive your for
forgive people right and so we are
looking at a world where forgiveness has
become impossible we see that on the
political sphere we see that in the
world around us so what's the solution
the solution is forgive people that's a
solution it's not complain because
because forgiveness is
impossible the solution is forgive
forgive others that's the solution
forgive your enemies like that's a rough
one it's a tough one but that's the way
to go I don't see another
solution what helps you in the project
of being a forgiving
person well I I would say the same I
would say that that that the the
testimony of the Holy ones like the
testimony of the saints that helps me uh
you know going conf that's do you have
one particular Saint that's been with
you uh I guess recently over the last
few years or throughout your life well I
I you know I don't know if you I mean
you know published this this graphic
novel called God's dog right yeah and so
that's about St Christopher who is a who
is a monster right St Christopher is a
doghe headed man or a giant you know and
I think St Christopher has been very
close to me
because as someone who's more
conservative right that I'm more of a
Christian that I'm that I'm more on that
side let's say of the of the situation
it's been helpful for me to meditate on
the on the Saint that's an exception on
on the Saint that's a monster on the
saint that doesn't quite fit so that I
can maintain compassion for that which
doesn't fit you know that I can always
keep that in mind that we're all kind of
not we're all kind of broken we're all
kind of doghe headed you know to some
extent and that we should be careful uh
in our Judgment of people like when I
watch you know when
I and I I to be honest like I when I see
people reposting Tik toks of obviously
broken people that are saying insane
things but that are obviously broken and
then just like getting you know
thousands of likes by reposting them to
mock
them I don't think that's the solution
like I don't think that helps anybody
you know the the a lot of the people a
lot of the blue-haired pink-haired
people that are you know cutting off
their breasts or that are doing this
stuff they are in deep deep suffering
and there's a difference
between not thinking that their actions
and the direction that they're aiming is
good you know there's a difference
between that like I can say I think this
is not good like I think that the
Direction with you're aiming that you're
aiming is is damaging to you and is
dangerous but there's a difference
between that and and mocking them or you
know pointing to them like you would in
a freak Show uh so I would say that
those are those are things that I try to
avoid getting involved in that's why I
said like the culture War stuff is
something that I and and some people
like confuse me with how can I say this
confuse me with my friends or confuse me
with people around me because obviously
you know I've done some things for the
daily wire I've done some things for you
know I've done things Peterson and these
are all people that I care about and
that I that I respect and that I admire
but you know I my my life and my
Approach is not exactly theirs right it
is it is my it is my approach and I and
I uh and I think anyway so I try to
avoid that kind of stuff as much as I as
I can let's say yeah which by the way
which is why that I love the I love your
approach I think your approach has been
very of all of all of the the kind of
YouTube approaches I think yours has
been fruitful because you speak to
people with compassion and you've been
able to to to talk to people who would
never speak to a right-wing whatever or
to to to but that are you know that are
that are very far on one side of the
culture world but that are willing to
talk to you because they know that
you'll give them true attention and you
won't try to trick them you won't try to
you know and trip them up and I think I
think that's a I think that's a great
approach I think that's way more
promising than a lot of the stuff that
we're seeing it's not as
prominent yeah it's a it's a it's a
different strategy it's a long slow yeah
you won't get you won't also get as many
clicks and you won't get as many views
obviously the culture war will get you
attention but you know I I I think that
the sacrificing that for something
better is is worth it you know it's
worth it to not play that game oh um we
should start wrapping up I do want to
you did just publish either a clip or a
video on sacrifice I think it was an
excerpt from another and I get I didn't
get to watch it cuz I was watching
another one of your um shows um but
could you just talk for a moment about
sacrifice and what it is to you
I was I was debating with I was I was
debating with uh somebody about
sacrifice and sacrifice being always
giving something up and and if you're
giving something up then you don't
really I just want to understand it
because it just means something to me
and and I know that you deal with that
symbolism as essential I think it's just
essential to my moral framework that was
given to me it's just like
sacrifices putting something aside to
gain not necessarily to gain something
else it's not just it's not just
transactional in that way I don't think
no I I so sacrifice you could say
sacrifice is the is the foundation of
reality um and uh this is obviously hard
for people to understand because we
don't live in the in an ancient world
again yeah and so the idea that you
would take something that is good for
example and that you would give it
up for something better right you would
or you would you would you would kind of
offer it up to something which is which
is more yeah not necessarily four but
two yeah something you sacrifice
something no no but how can I say this
maybe itent to some extent there is how
can I say this we have to we have to be
careful like I said not to make it
purely transactional um so let let me
give you an example that's very simple
that everybody can understand it's not
it's not magical in any way which is the
way that a sports team functions
right and so imagine all the players of
the team they want to be successful they
want to win they want to shine they want
you know to be the star of the game they
this is something that they they wrestle
with like this desire that they have to
to do that now the reality is that if
they grab on to that they'll lose yeah
they'll lose the game they'll lose the
prestige to lose everything and so the
only way for that desire to embed itself
properly in the game is for them to give
it up towards a higher purpose and they
say I will play in a way that my team
will win right I will play in a way that
will take into account the reality of
the other players so I will sacrifice an
aspect of my aspiration to a higher
good and the the the mystery is that if
you do
that that's how you get it in the proper
way that's actually how you that aspect
of you which is the desire to succeed
and to win and to do that will actually
shine so that's the mystery of sacrifice
right in the story of in scripture you
see that especially in the story of the
sacrifice of Isaac it's the most obvious
version of that which is
that God tells Abraham you know uh
you're going to have a son and he's like
in his 90s and it's like this ridiculous
thing like there's no way I'm have a son
not only you can have a son but your son
will have sons and you'll have so many
children right they'll become like the
stars of of heaven and so so finally in
his 90s God gives him a son and then God
says all right now go up the mountain
and sacrifice him to
me it's like what you just gave me this
thing this whole thing that I've
everything's been moving towards
everything's been moving towards me
having this son and now you're saying
sacrifice him to me so he goes up the
mountain and at the moment when he's
willing to give that up to God then God
gives him back and says now that it's
it's it's like now that you're will now
that I know that you're willing to give
this up towards a higher good that's how
you get it in its proper place that's
how that's how it and so you could say
so you could say that that's now again
this is true about everything right if
you if you if you love a woman and you
want to make love to her but that's the
only thing you want and you're driving
towards that and everything's driven
towards that
like you won't probably get it or not
not much but if but if it's given up
into a higher good of love and of
communion and of and of of of you know
aim towards something higher then the
surprise is that then it will be
returned to you like it will it will
come back into your life and that's true
about everything right that's how the
world actually works that's how Goods
scale is is if they give themselves up
into higher Goods and that's basically
the nature of sacrifice and what does
that tell us about love I think that
that that's kind of one of the answers
of Love Like Love is the process that we
witness when we participate in letting
go towards something higher that's right
that no that's a good that's a good
thing is that when
we that love always when you're
attentive to love you'll realize that it
only Finds Its fullness if it's
constantly giving up towards
the higher and that's the only place in
which it reaches fullness and every time
we stop and we think that this is the
top and it's like if I can only have
enough money like if I can only get my
retirement fund you know then everything
will be solved then you realize that no
it's like you're not going to
find uh satisfaction in that but if you
you know if you if you do those things
but you always scale them up towards
something which is more meaningful and
more powerful and more full full then
you know all those things you know what
is it that Christ says he says search
first for the kingdom of God and all
those things will be given to you that
is don't worry about the things the the
lower things if you aim to the top those
lower things they'll figure themselves
out like they will they will play
themselves out uh but if you try to
grasp any of them then you lose them you
know that's the the mystery is it is the
mystery of love but it's also that's the
nature of sacrifice that's what the
function of
sacrifice God is good but it's yeah but
you can so but it's funny because like
people don't understand it because they
see the ritualized version and then they
don't understand what ritual is for and
so they just see it as a weird thing
it's like okay so you go to this place
and then you kill a goat you know and
you burn it and you give it up to God
like what the hell are you doing like
what is this like what are you why does
this matter like why are you doing that
uh and you can only understand it if you
apply it like you can you can let's take
the family meal again a family meal is a
good example to understand sacrifice you
know you have a family potluck it's a
that's even better example right and so
everybody comes and everybody
offers their food up to the family right
to something Beyond them and so it's a
sacrifice right it's it really is that's
now you're really in the world of
sacrifice like you know Aunt so and so
she makes her casserole or whatever she
brings it to the potluck and then she
offers it up to the family and then the
the the the the blessing will come back
down right and so we will sit around the
table and then we'll have a feast we'll
eat the food right we'll get the food
but the food is offered up to the
family it's not just you standing at the
on the corner of your of your of your
table and just eating standing right
it's like it's a ritualized offering up
to the family and if you make an
improper
sacrifice you know what that what
happens right if you make an improper
sacrifice if you do it especially if you
do it quite a few times what do you mean
that that is that if you don't offer
your best right if everybody brings
their prepared meal and you come and you
don't you know you don't put any effort
into it that will affect
to some extent your participation in the
family it will affect or it will reflect
your participation in the family it will
it will reflect your Unity your your
participation in the unity of the family
yeah and so so that's exactly though the
the whole sacrificial system the
sacrifice is more complicated but that
part of the sacrificial system uh can
you you can understand it just by the
way in which you do things like that
right in the way in which you give the
way in which you give gifts to others
for example in which you take something
good and you give it to the friendship
that binds you to the other person
because obviously when you're giving a
gift to someone you're not just giving
it to the person you're offering it to
the union of both of you together that's
a sacrifice it's the same thing as when
people would offer goats up to God it's
just at a very at a at a lower level
yeah but
Stacks it Stacks that's right it
Stacks what's coming up for you do you
have any tours
I'm trying to not travel as much last
year was yeah last year was crazy you
know they especially because when Co
ended I just said yes to everything and
then all of a sudden I was like gone all
the time and so I've been trying to to
tone down the travel to have more time
with the family and also trying to find
ways to travel with my wife or with my
family uh so that you know it's not such
of a you know it's not such of a weird
situation um and so that's so that been
careful with that but I would think the
thing I'm most excited about is the is
the new publishing company do you know I
think you probably saw started a
publishing company called symbolic World
Press um and uh publishing Fairy Tales
um you know I'm writing eight fairy
tales that were publishing beautifully
Illustrated with uh yeah it's so it's
yeah let me show you I got it right here
please this is our our Snow
White yeah and it's it was illustrated
by Christ uh by Heather pollington who
is an amazing illustrator she's just
like just astounding yeah she's just
great yeah she's really good it's like
it's so I'm really excited about that
and we're we're working hard people can
buy that now yeah people can well I mean
we're we're shipping them right now
because we we did it as a crowdfunder uh
and so we actually today like it's
things are being shipped like like today
uh and so you get people can find it on
uh uh I still have a pre-order store
open on backer kit people can find if
the rights in the white Jonathan P or
something um and that's what I'm most
excited about because we're gonna we're
going to continue to publish the graphic
novels and then I'm going to write these
fairy tales as a kind of Symphony of of
fairy tales um and uh and yeah that's
the thing that I'm most excited about
although I still I'm still making videos
still doing the YouTube thing but it's
getting harder I feel how so feel like
I'm running out of the things that I
wanted to say it's like at some point I
pretty much said what I want to say and
I'm thinking okay what am I gonna talk
about you know yeah yeah yeah that
that's you find that but you have like
these discussions with
like all these people so yeah yeah well
I mean you get into you know it just
kind of comes and goes it's like life
you know it's like you know it rains and
then it then it dries up and my in and
also with my interest you know my like
do I really like am I do I want to talk
about gender anymore and yeah and then I
feel bad for my audience they want to
hear more about it and then I publish a
gender episode and a lot of people watch
it I'm like well at least you know at
least it's working at least the
Channel's working you know but like I'm
always I'm kind of looking for like
what's the new thing what's the next
thing like what what's cool what's next
what's what's good where's the good in
the world and I'm not really I don't
really that's what I that's why I I've
kind of moveed towards the idea of
telling stories yeah rather than just
talking about it so I've been talking
about symbolism for like five six years
now and I thought okay well I have to
stop just talking about it let's do it
let's tell better stories you know yeah
and since all the companies all the like
big media companies are just dropping
these these fairy tales they don't want
them anymore H just take them you know
because they're yeah it's an opportunity
it's amazing it's a great
[Laughter]
opportunity so uh people can order so
these books will be coming out over the
course of the next year or so these
books I mean so we're we're we're going
to try to speed we're going to like ramp
up so basically the idea is to you know
use the funds for the from the first
books to finance this the next ones and
so we had a pretty good run with the
crowdfunder and so we we're we're
financing the second one even starting
the third one uh and so hopefully we can
start to put them out regularly either
either two at a time or something we're
not sure um so yeah so it'll be coming
out soon we try to do it as fast as we
can but we definitely want them to be as
beautiful as possible that's
W to get my hands and some like to go
against the AI thing that's happening
right it's like to to to just say we're
g to make the most beautiful high
quality thought out uh
story and the idea is to use some
aspects of postmodern storytelling you
know this idea of self-referentiality
and Alo the idea of um of a kind of meta
awareness that you see in postmodern
stories like in Shack for example when
they they have this kind of weird uh
meta awareness of the of their
storytelling uh but to do that towards
Insight rather than towards cynicism oh
yeah it's a basic sorry yeah people
people mistake the postmodern uh tactics
for the postmodern goal and and you can
use those T the tactics are very rich
especially the artistic ones they just
don't they don't have they're not wedded
to cynicism people think that they're
wedded to like being met as cynical like
no it's not necessarily it's there's a
lot of fun there there's a lot of like
you break it apart to put it back
together you don't just break it apart
to break it apart you break it apart to
put it back together that's part of like
it serves the story it serves to Crea it
makes the story even more creative
because it engages the reader and the
reader you know is invited to particip
to embed themselves into the
interpretation of the story which is a
part of the story interpretation is a
part of the story it's not something
that comes after or controls the story
defines the story it's a part it's an
intrical part of the story it's a
participation part it's like where the
story it's like the genitals of the
story kind it's the part of the story
that that faces outward or that that
incubates the new yeah I totally agree
so all all the postmodern strategies of
Storytelling are like are there in
Shakespeare like they'll have plays
Within the play they'll have even even a
lot of the kind of confusing of identity
where you know it's like someone uh you
know pretending to be something playing
something else and so everything kind of
slips and starts to fragment and there's
a kind of awareness of the secret hidden
behind it all of these strategies are
are definitely useful and that's what so
basically that's what I'm trying to do
with fairy tales is to we're doing eight
fairy tales and they're going to become
symphonic As you move forward so we'll
set up a little like a a story and a
world at the beginning and then there'll
be crisscrossing as you move forward you
know with objects and people and
characters and surprises in the story uh
where you know you can use for example
Sleeping Beauty falling asleep to help
you understand Snow White falling asleep
so you can it's not just like a it's not
just a uh it's not just a an Easter egg
reference right it's like it's a
reference that now connects you and
helps you understand more deeply what is
going on there so basically using the
the repetitive nature of of um fairy
tales to actually bring more insight
into them anyways so there are few of
the strategies to use but that's the
idea and to make them in a way that you
can read it to an eight-year-old but
that as an adult you're also like huh
okay I didn't realize that that's what
was going on there you know like the the
okay so this is what this is what's
being uh referred to so hopefully bring
insight to adults as well but that's the
that's the play do you have a my wife
wants us to start a Bible study uh with
the kids and I'm wondering um like what
would be good for 12 where would you
start like if you're doing a a a Bible
reading for for 12 10 years olds what
you think David or Kings or judges or
yeah judges maybe not judges
no well I had to learn I had to learn
the hard way because with my kids I was
like I'm just going to tell them the
Bible stories and then I had them like
crying you know when they were
like okay that's not the way to go do
you start with lot and his daughters is
that exactly I right away with L and his
daughters that was the first story I
told them where like the in judges write
the story of the judge that cuts his the
his his mistress into 12 pieces like all
these crazy stories there are crazy
stories in the Bible for sure but um I
think that I think that uh kids should
know for sure Genesis is really
important you know the creation story
The Flood uh the story of Abraham um
Genesis Exodus those stories are are
crucial because they are pattern making
like they are really uh Cosmic in their
implications they they have the the
deepest levels of Storytelling in them
um and then then really the story of
Jesus so it's like the story Genesis
Exodus and Jesus is probably the best
place to to start with with kids uh and
then later you can go into uh you can go
into other stories like you can talk you
can go further into the Old Testament
you know taking the promised land and
then uh David King David all those
stories and then some of the stories of
the prophets like some of the stories of
Elijah and Elisha are really are really
interesting for kids but uh I would
start with that the one about U making
fun of a man a bald man yeah I made a
video about that about the the the she
the she bears that comes and eats the
young
people Goble Goble yeah well jonan thank
you so much for uh taking time on your
busy schedule to speak with me about
this you know I I I didn't want to talk
I didn't want a gossipy thing I just
want to kind of drill down into this
divide about how we approach this like
this really high level thinking about
like well if our society is just do
whatever you want um how do we survive
and and how do we start to collectivize
and and I think that you and James
basically have the same answer just in
different formulations like you have to
start with yourself and you have to not
be hum you're not the god of anybody
else like you you stand before reality
and you have to be honest and humble in
that and build it block by block and and
he's more of on the reason side and
you're more on the virtue side or like
like talk speak in in in terms of of
Love um you know and and and and that
but I think that you're both I I I don't
see any terrible divide between you two
so I wanted to like kind of facilitate
for my own mind for your own sake I
agree I don't have a problem with James
at all I always followed his work from
the very beginning I think that the work
he's doing uh you know showing the
relationship between uh between
communism and postmodernism
and showing the line you know you know
to to between the between grami and how
feeds into the 60s and then the
postmodern I think it's one of the most
useful things that is being done right
now in the in the intellectual life and
so I was
actually like kind of shocked that he
came after me with such vehement and I
was like okay like I guess but I am a
Christian I don't know what to tell you
I'm not going to change that and I do
believe that Christianity is the best
story uh but I don't identify as a
Christian nationalist I don't even know
exactly what that is I think it's think
it's I think it's a category
that was made up by people like Rob
Riner honestly uh so yeah so I anyway so
it's too bad but you know if he ever
wants to talk by the way if you watch
this I'd be happy to talk to him I don't
have a problem with him yeah no
absolutely maybe someday hopefully maybe
who knows I'm gonna end the recording
thank you very much for joining me all
right yeah
thanks